what a weekend for theatrical comedians
some very interesting news comes up
about our boy Hassan Minaj
minhaj minhaj I think yeah how do we
even know how do we even know that
that's how he pronounced I think we get
to decide what the truth is I think I
think that his name is 70 emotionally
true and then but the Arnold Palmer that
is his last name the Arnold Palmer is
his last name we're not exactly certain
on so I think it's something you just
flow with and you know it you know what
I mean yeah the actually annoying thing
about uh Hassan you're gonna get these
[__] jokes you deserved it but uh but
uh but I like I like a size he's a
Charming guy it's a nice dude it's
always been nice to me but you you
deserve this but uh the crazy thing
about the whole situation with him you
know lying in his uh specials or about
the stories and his specials is that
like if you know his real life he has
like these he has these insane things
that have happened to him like
completely separate like when he came to
America it was on a boat with a tiger
did really did you guys no dude I had no
idea yeah yeah it was actually yeah he
was like lost at sea and it was him and
a tiger on a boat and they like forged
they forged this like real French crazy
because that okay
tell that story that makes perfect sense
because the tiger yeah I went before he
came here I know he grew up in a jungle
like a bunch of animals raised him like
you know how to speak to them yeah yeah
yeah dude
the tiger he must have made good with
tiger [__] tiger was a real enemy yeah
dude they should make a movie on his
life honestly they could dude he told me
this one story about like going to White
Castle with his Asian friend and it was
like it was one of the most unbelievable
stories I've ever heard it was like so
many shenanigans
and I'm like why not do that yeah tell
the thing about how he really made his
money he won Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire [__] I forgot about it yeah
and just talk about that that's how he
met his wife
[Music]
dude that you can play off of them
anyway
um anyway so many things out there but
listen uh you know tons of material for
him to steal mine uh for for all of you
that are they're confused right now news
has come out there's a New Yorker
article that um Hassan minhaj uh may
have been fabricate fabricating some
things in uh his Netflix specials wait
but Andrew yes comedians make up stories
all the time that's true now usually we
do it
to make things funnier yeah not make
things more racist
or yeah or emotional yeah and I think
that's the tricky thing here with with
like in his stories it's not like he was
using these exaggerations or hyperboles
punch lines he was using them to kind of
make the audience feel worse about him
and then it turns out these things
didn't actually happen yeah he made life
worse for other people in real life oh
wait how is that have you you know the
prom story right what's the prom story
prom Story the homecoming King is based
on the story that he was supposed to be
a problem with a white girl got to the
door she's putting a corsage on another
a guy a white guy oh because her parents
didn't like the fact that Husson was
Indian and that's a terrible terrible
story yeah lady responds I know what I
picked and said
Union responds and it's like not only is
this not true he asked me days before
the prom I just said no and not only are
my parents not racist I'm married to an
Indian but here's the thing and this is
like
ah this is the problem when you lie in
your specials is like that girl
had to marry in India
wouldn't think she was the same face
yeah just to say so in a way Hassan
actually helped Indians yeah he did yeah
he might be a hero the ultimately he's a
patriot I didn't say God to marry an
Indian yeah
right but the rest of us would be like
oh
here's you got to put in on this they
should do that for India because that's
the first thing she says she's like I'm
not racist she had to [__] do it
because he bullied her into it but I do
like this idea that if a girl rejects me
she's racist because there's a lot of
racist brown girls that I didn't know I
see this girl because he's handsome my
son is handsome right he is he is he is
a handsome man great [__] hair we
have to look at this girl she might be
raises bro she might be ugly enough
where she's racist or we gotta see what
this white dude that she went to prom
looked like I think we need to do a
little research
I think we need to do a little research
I think we might have to defend us he
might be right about that one she might
have been racist okay okay got it
yeah bro I need to have that level of
confidence bro where if you don't like
me you're racist the only way you could
not like don't you wish objectively wish
you had that she got to be fat she got
to be fat this girl got to be fat
there's no way that she's a cutie
because he got to think he's doing her a
favor and then when she says no he's
like oh this [__] racist yeah yeah but
why say I went to the door you didn't go
to the door this was crazy he told me
that story like that's the most Indian
thing to go I'm here for a vagina and
Bob
now we all show up we just text you
nicely wait hold on he told you the
story in real life yeah like we were
cool a long time ago I'm talking like
2012 bro he and I used to be friends I
kind of realized whatever he but this I
didn't know this was a lie I thought all
the reasons I don't [__] with this guy
this wasn't one of them we're sitting at
a [__] Diner and he tells me this
story as a trauma story I'm dead-ass I
believe that this whole time he was
working it out son that's the craziest
[__] yeah we're just eating in and out
bro why you gotta lie to me you know
what you probably said something like
you went to their houses yeah and he was
like all right keep that part that was
good
Sonny said I got to the door this is any
joke to get me on his side obviously
he's like so he can't trust white women
and I was like yeah dog that makes sense
but I will be on I remember when he said
what his parents her parents said to him
it's just not a good fit and then I
remember being like that okay well your
parents would say the exact same thing
it's just not a good fit like this is
what both your parents would say that
more
your parents would be like [__] you
thinking man this is not a good fit
she's not in the same country not the
same race not the same Faith what's
going on that's not a good fit mad
incongruous yeah so I do remember
thinking that and then now he's happily
married happily married probably
wouldn't have happened if he was with
that white girl yeah white devil and
that white Devil's now married to an
Indian miserable
right line kind of works for him lines
I think I think one of the things that
we have to really separate is is there
are communions that plenty of us all of
us exaggerate things in our jokes to be
funny yeah or change things that's that
joke I did the uh the the not [__] me
joke yeah I tell her I was at a hotel
with my boy that didn't happen a hotel
we were at the selka and case oh yeah
and one of our friends goes yeah I go
yeah you can just crash at my place if
you want to go home and he goes yeah but
what and we could sleep head to toe or
put the pillows and I was like yeah or
you cannot [__] me in the joke it's
funnier to just make it in a hotel
absolutely so we change these things to
make parts of the joke funnier yes it's
a completely different thing it's
Jessie's Malay when you are lying about
victimization yeah so I don't like it
when people are starting to Target other
Comics who have things that aren't
exactly true this is not common he's not
lying about the funny part yeah if he
was like if he found a way to Anthrax
and the daughter thing is crazy I mean
what is that what is that in retrospect
it's funny
knowing that he was lying about that the
the idea that this guy wasn't the
funniest there's pure comedy in this but
actually every part is funny if you
realize none of it is true the whole
thing is hilarious this is the greatest
comic ever I think bro but think about
he got to do the what is it called when
you make fun of the president
White House Correspondents Dinner yeah
off of Lies
like that's correct getting sent anthax
levels you up because they only send
that to important people to the boss
and uh once his face got a shot too he
said uh so he he can played some
timelines to make what he went through a
little bit more serious he was making
fun of I think the Saudis and uh I have
less of an issue with this actually oh
that's fine that's fine I'm just telling
the people so so uh I guess in one of
the stories he was like making fun of
the Saudis and then he had a meeting
because he wanted to interview MBS it
was Muhammad bin Salim I think his name
is he is the guy who runs the Saudi uh
what is it pif it's called or plf
um all their money makes all the
decisions he's boss and um he went to go
meet with them and I guess he left and
everybody was freaking out because he
said the same day khashoggi was chopped
up at the Saudi Embassy in Turkey right
and uh people are going uh oh my God is
everything okay and uh he said something
about the meeting or the event that
night Jerry Kushner sat in a seat that
was reserved for this uh Saudi
journalist right and like apparently
Jared Kushner didn't even go to the
event yeah like it was just a complete
it was just a shot of him there was no
chair for him there was no chair yeah so
there was just a shot at Jared for no
reason and to your point the LIE there
was to make it it wasn't to be funny it
was to make himself a hero and then a
lot of the other lies that just kind of
add to what you said I think they're to
kind of like push I don't want to say an
agenda but to push a political agenda
for lack of a better way to say it
whereas if you are lying just to be if
the whole Bert Chrysler machine story
was fake I don't none of us think it is
but if it was who cares it's hilarious
we're just laughing at bird crisis that
would break my heart yo it would shake
your confidence and it would break my
heart if the machine story wasn't real
you've been calling the machine this
whole time for no reason no I wouldn't
care I'd be so happy with it I'd be more
impressed that you can make up that
whole last story I thought it was fake
come on
never went to Russia
that wouldn't bother you a little bit
actually bothering me a little bit a
little bit a little bit a little bit I
was using hyperbole
that's my emotional no no that's my
emotional truth
you were being emotional right there it
was beautiful I really want to
appreciate that I want to reward that
now here's the thing if if some of the
things said within the story have been
tweaked a little bit to be funny if he
makes the Russian person say something
funnier you're doing your job yeah as a
comedian that's great there's no way
that every single story a comedian says
when the Comedian says the perfect witty
thing back yes that that happened in the
moment because most comedians are
awkward as [__] in the moment and
they're not going to come up with that
line and that's why they'll go home and
they'll sit in the shower for an hour
and think about what they would have
said yeah and then that pops up in the
gym that's why I just want to separate
this from Comedy I hate that this is
like getting pulled in there people are
bringing up hilarious jokes the
Chappelle baby joke is [__]
hysterical we all know yes is sarcasm
which we all know isn't a real thing
yeah it's used to point out things that
might be real yeah but people go oh see
you can lie there you can like no no
Chanel's not lying about the emotionally
manipulative part he's not lying about
the victimization part yeah so I also
think a lot of those people didn't read
the full article because the headline is
like oh the stories aren't true big deal
yeah and then you read it and you're
like oh this is crazy This Woman's life
really heard her parents got death
threats this is crazy oh really yeah
yeah yeah the prom date so the
anthraction is too that's true that's
crazy that's crazy that's too good I
gotta mail myself some baby powders
level up in his business right the
anthrax got on his daughter and he had
to take her to the hospital
nobody asked about that you make your
daughter open up the mail can't be
honest though in the Indian house they
just make the youngest person go get
everything is that right yeah go get me
some water go get the mail go get this
you're just like you're like a golden
retriever yeah but for yeah just like
random things around him he'll get that
for me yeah
I mean wow bro yeah I mean just too
funny just too funny yeah and then he
got to lean in with this next one the
articles that he invited the girl from
the homecoming story to watch to watch
the show yes and apparently used a photo
of her in the show but then blurred out
her face with the brown boyfriend which
she obviously that ruins the whole story
about her being racist so he blurred his
face too yeah and I think he's still got
the braces I'm still I still need to see
this girl I still dude your emotional
truth you and him both think she was
racist you disagree that's it yeah we
agree on the emotional thing you agree
100 100 nothing wrong with that I think
she's racist you think she's racist and
who are we to tell you you're wrong
about another human I think she's hold
on a second I don't think she's racist
but I do think that she agreed to go to
prom with him
okay
well because he admitted that he was
like yeah her version is true but I I
but he's always he's got to do that
because he's he's super Lefty so he's
got you know women are always right I
have to agree but deep down he knows
he's super left to you but he's also
super Muslim so women aren't always
right
no answer because
that's not true either that's cause he's
Indian oh there you go so listen it's a
cultural thing like she was like No And
he was like yes
he's like let me talk to your parents
they'll arrange this thing you'll be
able to make these decisions yeah yeah
yeah matter of fact if he did go talk to
the parents and then he maybe would have
respected it they're like no it isn't a
fit yeah yeah the star signs don't align
is doing math and they just ask her
numbers and there's like 55 plus 72 plus
105 and she's just doing Abacus in her
head you haven't seen this video I'm
talking about the the Indian show where
sure
so here's the question I would like to
know what shorty looks like but I guess
her picture's not out there I can't find
it yeah because to turn down Hassan I
will say though
I know you want to be the hottest it did
but yeah
how much did you pay that that New
Yorker writer dude
how about you pay that [__] hey
this is my special
that's mostly true
Hassan is out of here it's emotionally
wow those are the two special bring back
a poo get rid of Hassan that's what he's
got Netflix budget is wide open wide
open dog yeah I gotta hey I gotta feel
it do you feel like the article was a
little bit of a hippie though yeah
because shorty was definitely
emotionally manipulated by you know that
whoever wrote it was riding for her son
for like five years and then randomly
was at a bar who was like oh what here's
what happened uh it better be exactly
what happened for you to cut off my
little Frontline it better be the exact
thing that happened because your boys
Building momentum I was about to 70
truth you and I was about to give you
the nice
journalist friend of ours fill me in the
New Yorker was doing a feature on him oh
and they fact checked the New Yorker
fact checks everything they don't [__]
around that's like their reputation he
just kept lying to them he kept telling
him all these stories as facts so they
started fact checking them and then
nothing was adding up like the daughter
hospitalization sure there's there's no
record hospitalization record the
building didn't have any record of
anything they like were very thorough yo
that's some wild [__] to like hold on to
the
to hold on to the LIE outside of the
show said he lied to me at an in and out
I need to sit down juicy Hassan and you
gotta add Santos in that yeah yeah come
on nose is the goats right there yeah
imagine that Barbershop talk
juicy smoothie right LeBron lying about
all the books you read yeah juicy smulee
George Santos parents on The Blind Side
phenomenal podcast should we arrange
this yeah we need to I think we should
it's open it's the most oh gosh that's
known about Indian [__]
oh my God that was phenomenal video
after the Pod was like I usually the
same thing she grew up in India you want
to make you feel better
I told Emma the story yeah and Emma's
been to India and she was like yeah I
saw that on all the buildings too I knew
it was to let like I knew it was yeah
she's Jewish she knows how to Homeland I
mean she knows don't start their movers
tour announcements first of all Long
Island thank you all so much man six
sold out shows the Paramount that was
unbelievable thank you to everybody who
came out this weekend we're in Niagara
Falls that sold out and when Windsor
Ontario at the Coliseum at the Caesars
some tickets left for that pull up also
Dublin thank you guys so much we're
adding more seats this has been
incredible the three arena in Dublin
iconic location we just added more seeds
so go get those as soon as you can
Manchester you've been asking we added a
second show okay London we're not adding
another show so if you're from London or
any of the surrounding areas get dressed
on a train come up to Manchester we're
doing a 4 P.M show that same day as
October 15th uh also November 13th we
added a second show in Perth Australia
okay Melbourne we just added more seats
in the John Kane Arena uh Sydney we
added a second show uh at the aware
super theater and unbelievable theater
in Sydney cannot wait to get in there
and uh we also have Brisbane
Entertainment Center in Brisbane that's
November 19th we'll see you all there
all those tickets dandrashells.com and
uh some cool announcements coming soon
all right also guys show announcements
first of all thank you to everybody who
came out of Stress Factory it was crazy
we sold all four shows out super quickly
added a fifth show that sold out super
quickly sorry we could not add a sixth I
truly did not have the time uh but I'm
gonna take a little time off of stand up
try to get my brain right
um but I'll be back in Atlanta October
27th 28th and 29th and if there's not a
lot of low-key gay dudes trying to [__]
me at all three of these shows I'm I'm
gonna feel very unattractive so I want
Indians openly gay dudes low-key gay
dudes and I think I just described all
of Atlanta
women too women I forgot if I forgot
half the population anyway after Atlanta
next show on the docket is December 1st
and 2nd in Portland Oregon uh and then
December 8th in New Orleans Louisiana
and I have a big announcement coming for
y'all next week buckle the [__] up
people been asking me from a very
specific region where to perform and
it's not India I will do India but y'all
got to get your exchange rate in order
but there's one more big show coming
you'll see what it is oh guys and before
I forget we did twitch stream the NFL
this past Sunday then I realized uh I
ain't got no real following on Twitch so
we moved over to YouTube where your boys
getting close to a million and it was
fun as [__] so we're gonna do it again
next week comedy on YouTube subscribe if
you haven't already let's hit a million
but either way NFL this Sunday hey
what's up guys we're gonna do the
world's fastest dates announcement
thrawn of September 28th come see me and
Derek posting comedy bar let's get back
to the show so what do we do with this
what is what are the repercussions do
you think this affects some career-wise
what is the I don't know I hope it does
because I have a special
oh there's no way like he was like a
front runner you can't branding wise he
seems like an obvious choice I don't a
branding wise is obvious skill wise he's
obvious I mean he's an excellent host
yeah he's fantastic they should have
offered him way before this article
um but the show I mean The Daily Show is
supposed to be about truth right like
you're supposed to so the guy who is
admit to not telling the truth
um can't host the truth show I think the
Daily Show would get too much criticism
that being said I don't think I don't
think that his fan base will care that
much and I think he'll still be able to
tour and still be able to make you know
these pieces and maybe they'll go into
it with a little bit more realistic
Viewpoint or maybe it'll change how he
does the shows now that he's you know
felt the repercussions because this is
bring back a poo the whole ethos is
we're not victims so watching the
tromedy thing get exposed where like
these South Asian dudes are like dude
were these victims of systematic
oppression it's like no you're not dude
they're kind of co-opting the blacks
yeah and it's like look I ain't no
[__] Ally but I'm not gonna call
myself
in America where the rich we're richer
than white people on average we're
killing everyone we're not victims we're
killing it what richer than you on
average miles how did we let this happen
hey you didn't let myself
but I don't think nothing happens though
yeah I don't think this affects them at
all you don't think you don't think the
Daily Show thing would no I think he
still can host that no one cares about
[__] anymore
like nobody cares that's interesting
that I think there is less of a concern
probably now about things and his life
didn't really hurt besides the project
shorty like his lies didn't hurt anybody
the only I think he'll be fine I think
kind of like Aziz is still killing it
but some people felt when it like let
down by like this guy that was just
getting woke he's still doing theaters
he's still you know what I mean he's not
yeah he's got a movie that he made like
I just haven't seen him no no I think it
might be like that where like a lot of
dude brown people worshiped this guy
that was their guy they felt all these
things that happened to him I mean FBI
informant [__] like all that spoken to
them
did you hear he actually has him to prom
it's the real story
yes
it's insane dude it's insane so the FBI
informant story is that this FBI
informant infiltrator is in mosque going
on for September 11th yeah and that's
[Applause]
I guess his parents like took him in and
then he was like asking all the brown
kids they're like what do you know about
Jihad and then her son was like I
decided to have fun with him and I told
him I'm getting my pilot's license that
night Cops show up by my house slammed
my hood on my face on the hood of the
police car door or whatever all this
crazy [__] and then the story turns out
to not be true and they said what is
that you know what's your emotional
Truth for that one he was like well I
was playing pickup basketball with these
white guys one of them fouled me kind of
hard
I love this any girl that rejected me is
racist a lot of racists brown girls out
there [__] hate boys
yeah skinny fat you know what I mean you
ain't seen my shirt off like reject me
that sucks bro remember you ask a girl
hey are you racist she's gonna go no I'm
not racist that guy's a liar she is
every incentive to lie oh yeah man [__]
I was right yeah that's what I'm saying
you're right I was right yeah yeah I
don't think that we could trust this
girl and be honest I don't think that we
could trust this girl no don't fix it I
I do I think we have to we have to meet
the husband okay who's the husband
he's actually not married to a brown
woman doesn't have brown kids he's
married to a blonde hair blue-eyed white
girl blue-eyed white girl yes Scooby-Doo
take the mask off yes whoa yes
jumps on you Akash married a brown woman
I [__] up you [__] up you could have
actually achieved the American dream yes
which is Alex
minorities marrying white women yeah
this is the American dream
white powder baby
want some white girl in the mail
dude it's a metaphor